je me souviens de ce jour de ce film
c'est là que tout a
commencé je n'avais jamais vu une merde
pareille une merde
pareille prochainement mais passons
parce que le pire de cette soirée
c'était quand même le film c'était
scandalant je n'en revenais pas de mes
yeux ou quelque chose comme ça et dans
leur folie un jeu a même été créé avec
ce film
[Musique]
c'est ce jour-là que j'ai décidé de
devenir une légende un symbole pour la
société et d'avoir une voix exagérément
grave je suis
[Musique]
devenu
je suis
canardman le testeur de jeu
[Musique]
rétro 1 2 3
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
salut tout le monde aujourd'hui on va
tester un nouveau jeu qui sera sûrement
pourquoi tu as une voixussi grave non
mais c'est parce que j'ai un masque
attends 2 secondes ah voilà attends je
vais poser ça dans un coin dans un coin
quoi quoi euh non rien laisse tomber
salut tout le monde j'adore Batman c'est
mon héros de comics préféré blab bla
blabla et cetera est-ce que vous
connaissez
ça Batman et Robin alors ça c'est le jeu
mais est-ce que vous vous souvenez du
film parce que avant que ce film
n'arrive Batman c'était classe c'était
énorme on avait eu la Super Série de 92
on avait eu les deux films de Tim Burton
qui sont encore pour moi d'ailleurs les
meilleurs films de Batman existants
ensuite ça avait déjà commencé un peu à
tourner avec Batman Forever mais bon le
film avait été sauvé de la noyade par le
charisme de Jim carré et en 97 sort le
dernier Batman pour un bon bout de temps
Batman et Robin traiter ce film de merde
ça serait insulter la merde pour bien
comprendre mon dégoût sur ce jeu je suis
obligé de faire un petit aparté sur le
film W super effit de montage ta gueule
déjà un film qui commence par des gros
plans de C et de téton c'est oh mon
dieu
le film met en scène TR méchants de
l'univers de Batman Mister
freze jeésac
leut mieux avir en fait le CAT mexicain
et poison don le costume la coiffure est
quelque part Memin entre cosplay raté
d'un salon comic d'Europe de l'Est et
une put du bois de Boulogne non mais
vraiment on dirait Peggy de mari deux
enfants alors évidemment qu'il dit
mauvais film dit mauvais jeu d'acteur et
là George Cloun fait fort parce qu'il a
l'air d'en avoir mais rien à
[ __ ] en fait je crois que le meilleur
acteur de tout ce film ça doit
être il nous cherche des crosses vieux
frère je te les oignerai avec Cho
diamants tu vas perdre tes feuilles
vieille branch ne compte pas me mettre
au
fr
oui bon ben je crois que c'est elle
c'est la meilleure actrice du
film ça force l'admiration quand même
normalement dans un mauvais film il y a
toujours des haut et des bas mais mais
là dans ce film on voit bien qu'ils ont
fait des efforts pour que ça reste
constamment à chier tout le long du film
regardez-moi cette scène franchement
c'est quoi ces véhicules même les effets
spéciaux de la soupou étai plus réaliste
mesames et
messieursz applaudir
acrobes vous avez déjà regardé un
épisode de B c'est un peu pareil en fait
c'est tellement perché que vous arrivez
pas à en
[Musique]
décrocher il me faudrait une heure pour
parler de tout alors je vais résumer ça
avec un seul extrait 6 million alors 7
[Musique]
millions je ne m'envole jamais sans elle
ici voilà là c'est le moment précis où
Batman est mort après ça on reverra plus
de film Batman pendant dans les 8 années
qui ont suivi ah oui on m'a dit que je
parlais pas suffisamment des bons côtés
dans mes tests donc voilà quand même le
meilleur moment de Batman et
[Musique]
Robin bref revenons au jeux vidéo he les
jeux sur Batman il y en a eu sur
absolument tous les supports depuis le
premier Batman sur amstrade en 86
jusqu'au dernier jeu sorti aujourd'hui
Batman Arkam zilom qui est réellement un
pur bonheur à jouer alors ces jeux
Batman des fois c'était bien des fois
c'était vraiment trop dur et des fois
c'était carrément à chier et là
aujourd'hui va regarder un jeu tellement
à chier que je vous conseille de
préparer quelques accessoires avant de
regarder la suite de cette vidéo le jeu
est développé par une entreprise qui
s'appelle prob ou sonde en français donc
forcément un jeu qui va rester dans les
anales voilà ça c'est fait le jeu donc
s'ouvre comme pour le début du film sur
la fusion du logo de Batman et Robin W
et le jeu commence donc dans la
Batcave comme on peut le voir c'est ici
dans la Batcave qu'on pourra changer de
personnage d'ailleurs pour les besoins
du film Robin a abandonné son logo
classique en R pour un logo à la Batman
et exclusivement pour le jeu ce coupci
badgir a désormais aussi son propre logo
voilà donc en gros c'est le même logo
que Batman mais avec un vagin c'est très
classe mais bon bref commençons par le
début alors déjà pour vous rituer un peu
ce jeu Batman et Robin c'est sorti 2 ans
après le premier Tomb raiderin c'est le
jeu de référence pour tout ce qui est du
combat à la trè personne et de la
plateforme d'ailleurs souvent on peut
juger la qualité d'un jeu rien qu'à son
tutoriel par exemple le tuto Raider éta
très clair très simple et très bien fich
pourou pass donc voyons un peu le tuto
de Batman et Robin maintenant alors déjà
pour commencer les deux premiers conseil
te mettre bien dans l'ambiance alors
déjà pratiquer les mouvements dont les
Capet crusadur sont capables de faire ok
conseil suivant on peut détruire cette
fenêtre à coup de point d'accord alors
un point avec un T c'est ça hein mais
bon passons et donne-vous accès à la
salle de gym
ok parfait mais moi ce que j'adore dans
ce tuto c'est surtout quand t'interrompe
en pleine action pour te dire un conseil
hyper utile du genre pour sauter appuyer
sur le bouton
saut merci captaine
obvious vous pouvez sauter au-dessus de
ce trou facilement oui j'aurais pu si tu
ne m'avais pas coupé en plein élan
connard
oui non ça tu l'as déjà dit
euh
allô non mais qu'est-ce qui se passe
dans dans ce jeu rendez le tutoriel et
le truc par que des gens complètement
dans tous les
non est-ce que le mec qui a fait le tuto
à joué au jeu est-ce que le mec qui a
fait le jeu joué au tuto et franchement
je crois que non quand tu lis des trucs
comme ça pour des sa cours avancer en
marchant et utiliser le bouton de saut
sur le côté donc ça veut dire que pour
sauter devant il faut marcher et sauter
sur le côté pour aller
devant
quoi et le tuto pour le combat c'est
pareil et maintenant le bouton de
défense ok le bouton de défense c'est
gentil mais c'est quoi le bouton de
défense me dis pas d'appuyer dessus tu
dis pas lequel c'est il est marqué nulle
part même dans les touches du jeu en
option il est mentionné nulle part le
bouton de
défense en mode Aventure utiliser le
bouton de défense va te faire
[ __ ] c'est incroyable j'ai même pas
encore commencé le jeu c'est déjà un
cirque un tuto ça doit être simple et
clair ça sert à rien de te harceler
toutes les 2 secondes avec un conseil
inutile bon voilà le tuto c'est fait
donc on va un peu se pencher sur le jeu
en lui-même une grosse partie du jeu est
un jeu d'exploration qui se déroule dans
les rues de Gottham donc pour ça nous
allons avoir besoin de la Batmobile et
là je m'excuse mais je fais une
parenthèse sur la Batmobile la Batmobile
normalement c'est une voiture noire
évoquant légèrement une chauve-souris
mais la Batmobile de Batman et Robin je
vous jure qu'on dirait une voiture de
rabatteur pour boîte de nuit non mais
sérieusement Batman il est pas censé se
déplacer discrètement vous savez Batman
la nuit tout ça mais là bonjour la
bagnole là c'est soirée tuning chez
Jacky un girophard orange à l'avant des
bandes rouges lumineuses sur le côté un
capot fluo et des jantes bleues
phosphorescentes attends c'est plus la
BAT mobile là c'est la BOF mobile
franchement il lui manque plus la queue
de renard sur l'antenne et c'est bon
allez bref ceci dit c'est parti pour
[Musique]
Gotham d'ailleurs une dernière chose sur
la Batmobile peut-être vous l'avez vu
mais il y a pas de vitre sur cette bat
mobile donc ça doit vraiment avoir la
classe quand il se déplace dans les ru
de gotam
clairement bon sinon je reviens
rapidement sur les personnages puisque
comme j'ai dit au début l'originalité de
ce jeu c'est que vous pouvez jouer
Batman bad girl
ou
Robin voilà voilà et maintenant Robin et
badgir vous les regardez bien et vous
les oubliez parce que je vous jure que
ces deux personnages sont aussi utiles
que la [ __ ] d'un papa bad girl déjà
c'est simplement un impossible de jouer
avec Bad Girl alors c'est la plus rapide
du jeu ok mais elle est complètement
inutile au combat quelintérêt d'avoir un
personnage qui court vite si c'est pour
se faire péter la rondelle dès qu'on
croise un ennemi mais ENF je viens de
faire les tro premiers ennemis du jeu
j'ai déjà plus de vie c'est
ridicule et Robin sérieux ben c'est
pareil quo que non en fait c'est pire
puisquil réussit l'exploit de combiner
les défauts de Batman et de Bad Girl non
vraiment là je comprends pas l'utilité
d'avoir mis ces deux personnages à part
pour respter le quota d' handicapé dans
la BAT cave quoi le seul avantage de ce
jeu il faut le reconnaître c'est que
c'était le premier jeu qui permettait de
se déplacer comme ça dans une ville en
3D non c'est pas
vrai le le seul avantage de ce jeu il
faut le reconnaître c'est que c'était un
jeu qui permettait de de couper du
jambon ah
oui oui oui voilà c'est vrai que j'ai du
mal à comprendre les rues de Gotham sont
misérablement vide tu croises tout juste
quelques mecs paumés des nanas qui font
la roue et des milliers de voitures de
criminels quand tu la conduite de la
Batmobile c'est rigolo 5 minutes mais
c'est tellement mal foutu que ça devient
vite gonflant c'est vraiment une honte
quand tu sais que la société qui a fait
Batman et Rubin c'est les mêmes qui ont
fait d'Ur trilogie 2 ans plus tôt et
c'était largement
meilleur la première mission nous fait
donc aller vers le musée où freeze tente
de voler le bijou et c'est réellement là
que l'horreur commence parce que c'est à
partir de là qu'on se rend compte que
tout dans ce jeu est à chierier je veux
dire virus est un jeu pas si mal
finalement à côté de Batman et Robin et
je pèse mes mots non non vraiment ce qui
se passe dans ce jeu c'est grave c'est
grave et en plus si on est fan de
l'univers de Batman mais jouer à ce jeu
c'est aussi plaisant que de se prendre
un concombre dans le
cul quand j'ai testé ce jeu je vous jure
que c'est vrai j'avais vraiment mal à la
tête et envie de vomir au bout de 20
minutes déjà pour commencer les musiques
bon là c'est celle du film bon là-dessus
j'ai pas grandchose à dire par contre
niveau son et bruitage depuis que j'ai
joué à Batman et Robin j'écoute tous les
matins mon album de chien qui AB bois et
de bébé qui pleure parce que je vous
jure que c'est vachement mieux que les
bruitages de ce jeu en
fait vous entendez ce son d'alarme
insupportable qui se relance en boucle
tout le
temps et bien ça dure absolument tout le
niveau et j'ai l'impression en plus que
c'est partout pareil quand tu arrives
sur les lieux d'un crime c'est
ça
et dans le niveau 2 qui met des heures à
se faire pendant la totalité du niveau
du début à la fin vous entendez
ça ils ont pété les plans mais c'est
c'est plus un défaut du jeu à ce stade
c'est carrément médicalement
dangereux ensuite la caméra de ce jeu a
été
programmée par par un singe je je je
vois que ça comme explication c'est pas
possible je crois qu'en fait il y a un
programme qui détermine automatiquement
quel est le plus mauvais endroit pour
placer la caméra et qui s'y déplace à
chaque fois c'est juste
misérable je sais que c'est un problème
récurrent des premiers jeux en 3D la
caméra qui s'affole dans les endroits
exigus mais là franchement la caméra un
coup elle est là tout va bien et juste
après attention
disparu niveau graphisme et animation
c'est moche
niveau animation je vais prendre un truc
typique pour illustrer pour grimper dans
les conduits d'aération les développeurs
n'ont même pas pris la peine d'animer ça
à la manière d'un Tomb Raider non non
ils avaient la flemme donc en gros tu
appuies sur X et hop ça te téléporte
dedans ce qui nous amène au problème
suivant ce jeu est ridiculement sombre
est-ce que vous voyez quelque chose là
si oui vous êtes un Lougarou ce qui
soulève des questions autrement plus
graves sin non c'est comme moi pour
jouer efficacement à ce jeu il faudrait
mettre la luminosité à fond mais ça rend
le jeu encore plus lait le jet boost
c'est la même animation que quand tu es
immobile les roulades sont moches les
combats sont moches les personnages sont
moches et quand Batman plane alors là
c'est un instant magique franchement on
dirait Phantomas tellement c'est mal
foutu non vraiment ce jeu a été codé par
des [ __ ] de
branleurs niveau jouabilité mais il y a
vraiment trop de trucs à dire quoi
Batman est lent même en mode Course vous
faites tout juste que trottiner
tranquillement les enchaînements de
combat sont irréalisables simplement
parce qu'il existe des les monstrueux
entre le moment où vous appuyez sur le
bouton et le moment où le jeu effectue
l'action mais moi ce qui m'a le plus
gonflé c'est un détail mais c'est que le
bouton pour sauter n'est pas utilisable
en combat à chaque fois que tu as besoin
de sauter il faut passer en mode
recherche où là à l'inverse tu peux plus
taper
oh par exemple si vous n'avez plus de
Batarang et que vous avez besoin de
prendre un conduit en hauteur vous devez
d'abord casser la grille donc ça veut
dire que en moins de une demiseonde vous
devez sauter changer de mode pour passer
en mode combat sinon vous ne pouvez pas
frapper et ensuite appuyeer sur
frapper voilà un pur
plaisir [ __ ] qu'est-ce qu'on s'éclate
dans le Grenet ah ça me
gonfle est-ce que ça c'est une
utilisation normale de la manette [ __ ]
de il y avait pas de bouton là-dessus
franchement sur une manette de
playstation pourquoi est-ce qu'un bouton
qu'on utilise tous les 5 [ __ ] de
secondes dans le jeu n'est pas un des
boutons principaux
merde non là franchement là je m'avoue
un cul non non seulement tous ces
problème ça te ruine le plaisir mais en
plus j'ai même pas réussi à passer le
deuxème niveau en gros il faut aller
dans une bijouterie pour empêcher un
crime si tu arrives à 20h50 c'est fermé
il y a pas moyen d'entrer et si tu
reviens 5 minutes plus tard les ennemis
ont déjà tout dévalisé c'est fantastique
ça moi je comprends pas ce qu'il faut
faire là pourtant j'ai fait ce niveau
dans tous les sens hein alors déjà il y
a tellement d'interrupteur que au bout
de 5 minutes tu sais même plus ce que tu
fais des fois ça ouvre rien des fois ça
ouvre quelque chose et ça te le montre
mais vu que tous les couloirs se
ressemblent ça te sert à rien du tout il
y a des interrupteurs qui éteignent les
lumières d'autres qui les allument le
jeu te dit de suivre les lumières pour
activer les interrupteurs super les
lumières laquelle la verte la bleue la
jaune la rose [ __ ] la la les
interrupteurs te disent que le coffre
est entre part alors ça c'est génial
super ça m'aide vraiment sauf que le
coffre en plus j'y suis et il y a que
dal j'ai beau avoir activé tous les
interrupteurs la moitié des grilles
reste fermé donc le seul truc que je
fais dans ce niveau depuis 2h c'est de
tourner en rond comme un connard sans
savoir quoi
faire en en fait je pense
que en fait je pense que ce jeu est un
laxatif c'est simple en fait c'est en ce
sens on peut dire que le jeu respecte
bien le film he puisque les deux te
donnent envie de gerber allez ça suffit
c'est c'est
bon tu vas connaître la colère
maintenant de
[Musique]
canarman encore une victoire pour un
canard
[Musique]